[Music]
it's like the new orphan movie which i'm
ridiculously excited about
thank you yeah it's exciting it was fun
to work on i
do not watch horror movies and
when i sent the script for it i was like
i don't know i'm not
i'm not into that genre but then and i
was also really worried about
going back to work after covid and the
script was so dang good
i couldn't put it down and i was so
surprised by the twist that i'm not
going to give away that
um i think you like it avoiding any
spoilers or twists
because you're someone who doesn't
necessarily gravitate towards watching
horror movies what what is a quality
about this new orphan movie that
you know i guess scratch that itch for
you that other ones don't
it's incredibly psychological you know
i'm not really interested in blood and
gore
and i don't find that i find it gross i
don't find it really scary what i find
scary is
is the stuff that happens up here and
the the um isabelle fuhrman's character
uh esther oh she has multiple names
laina i don't know
um is it's just such a fascinating
uh especially now because she's a
grown-up she's 23 now playing the same
part it's like it's just such a
fascinating
um sociopathic character i mean along
the lines of why norman bates was so
interesting to watch
you